Nice guys finish last - at least that’s
how the saying goes. But we’re here to destroy
this myth and show you with scientific research
and evidence, how nice guys, undoubtedly,
finish first.
There’s a neat problem called the The Prisoner’s
Dilemma that has boggled many intelligent
minds for decades. There are many variations,
but in ours, two people face off against each
other, with 2 different cards in their hands.
One says “COOPERATE” and the other says
“DEFECT”. Each round, both players pick
one of the cards and play it face down without
the other knowing which they’ve chosen.
If both players choose “COOPERATE” then
they each win $300. If both players play “DEFECT”
they both lose $10. But if one person plays
“COOPERATE” and the other plays “DEFECT”,
the person who played “DEFECT” wins $500
and the “COOPERATE” card loses $100.
So, how is this a dilemma? Well, if I were
to play the card DEFECT, your best move would
also be DEFECT. Sure, we both lose some money,
but you haven’t lost as much as if you were
to play COOPERATE. And if I were to play COOPERATE,
your best move would still be to play DEFECT
- because you would win the most money. So
no matter what the other does, DEFECT is always
our best, most logical move. And yet, if we
both play our smartest move, we will always
lose - fully knowing that if we had simply
COOPERATED we could have won $300.
But here’s the really interesting part;
scientists have created computer simulations
to analyze and discover which strategy is
the best to win the most money over hundreds
of turns. And the winner was one called “Tit
for Tat”. It was programmed to always start
with COOPERATE and after that it would copy
the last move of its opponent. So if your
opponent DEFECTs, then next time you DEFECT.
If they COOPERATE, then you COOPERATE next
time. Using this method not only helps to
prevent you from getting duped over and over,
but statistically, leads to the highest earnings
in all simulations, when compared to any other
strategy.
Ok so how does this relate to nice guys? Well,
it turns out the top ranked strategies were
almost all the ones that begin with what the
scientists classified as “nice(ness)”.
That is, they would never be the first to
defect, and would always cooperate first.
Furthermore, strategies which were quick to
forgive others for deceiving them, and ones
that were non-envious aka happy when others
won just as much money, were key factors to
success. On the other hand, the more devious
strategies that tried to trick or defect more
often, while temporarily gaining more, actually
scored worst over the long term. Seriously,
out of 15 strategies, the top 8 scores came
from those which contained ‘nice’ strategies,
while the bottom 7 were more nasty or devious.
And this niceness, forgiveness and non-envious
behaviour pays; not only in monetary terms
like our game, but even in the real world,
from an evolutionary perspective.
Shockingly, we can actually see these strategies
right in nature. Many birds, for example,
must work together to remove ticks in hard
to reach spots - both can cooperate and help
each other out, whereby they both use energy
but also benefit, or one can receive help
and then not return favour. But it turns out
that selfish birds are completely shunned
from these communities. Vampire bats, on the
other hand, hunt for blood in the night but
occasionally don’t find any. To increase
their group success, the ones who do find
blood will share it with those who don’t,
with the understanding that on their off nights,
others will help them out. And ultimately,
all the bats are more successful if they carry
this trait. However, just like the Tit for
Tat strategy, if a bat is selfish and doesn’t
share, others are less likely to share with
it. Those who are nice are more successful.
From an evolutionary perspective, animals
which contain genes that promote nice behaviour
are likely to have more offspring. It’s
the basic underlying code for altruistic behavior
- you help me and I’ll help you. And ultimately,
we’ll all do better!
So while some mean, cut-throat, or envious
people may temporarily exploit and gain from
others, in the long run, not only nice guys,
but nice people, really do finish first.
If you want to learn more about the human
condition and altruism, check out the book
“The Selfish Gene” by Richard Dawkins,
which this episode was based on. And if you
like a good deal on books, especially textbooks,
we’ve teamed up with our friends at slugbooks.com
to get you the cheapest prices for the books
you need. Seriously, we know how expensive
textbooks, in particular, can be, so all you
have to do is head to SlugBooks.com/AsapSCIENCE
and search the ISBN number of the books your
looking for. SlugBooks will then compare prices
from all across the net, and hopefully save
you some money!
Don’t forget, our own AsapSCIENCE book is
now on pre-sale too! Links are in the description
for that.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!